[Music]
you know what I'm gonna say here we go
again
the PlayStation Plus offerings for the
month of May 2019 have been revealed
we'll be able to get our digital hands
on them from Tuesday the 7th of May so
if you're ready let's do this game
number one is overcooked a local co-op
game based around kitchen etiquette and
working alongside your fellow chef Burt
in reality it's a front it cook against
the clock which will have you swearing
like God and Ramsey in a matter of
minutes over cooks takes teamwork to the
next level as chopping frying cooking
serving and even washing up must be done
to such a high pace it most definitely
can become stressful and when someone
forgets to take the pan off at the right
time then the kitchen goes up in flames
honestly it's a great deal of fun with
friends and as couch co-op is dying I
recommend it
the controls are simple enough a
four-year-old can play but the levels
become ultra hard so you need to perfect
the right approach another cool thing
about overcooked is that two players can
simultaneously use one controller so you
don't need four controllers to play ball
player pretty cool other cooks won't
last you a long time but it will keep
you coming back for more reviews
averaged out to about 85 out of 100 not
bad at all are you trying it I'd love to
know your thoughts game number two this
month is what remains of Edith Finch a
first-person adventure game which is all
about exploration and detective style
sleuthing arriving at the Finch house we
slowly uncover what happened to eat it
and her family the real draw to what
remains of Edith Finch is the
storytelling if you are intrigued by a
missing character and invest in
uncovering their story the final payoff
is great I'd call this a game for movie
and TV goers rather than the typical
hardcore gamer we jump to the game will
take around 100 minutes - about two
hours to complete it's relaxing it's not
too taxing and will leave you thinking
about Edith for days afterwards I've
already said too much what remains of
Edith Finch was praised almost
universally with scores of nine and
eight out of ten will you try it share
your thoughts below so what do you think
to this month's offerings happy sad
delighted man share your thoughts below
tell us what you think if you've decided
not to renew your PS Plus this month you
consider the free-to-play market many
games have PS plus integrated in them
but others don't
one such a game is world of warships and
legends it's essentially up to nine
players going to war on the Seas in
ships designed around their real-life
counterparts I've been working alongside
wargaming to put together a quick
overview and beginner's guide to battles
on the 7c I'll link it now for some
cheeky self-promotion you can go down
the free-to-play route and earn ships as
you play or if you'd like to support the
game further different paid editions are
available to speed up the grind and
unlock unique ships to stand out from
the crowd I've been playing for around
25 hours and can confidently say the
teams are balanced so you won't find a
team full of tier 7s fighting a team of
beginner cruisers you'll face opposition
at your own level or even choose to play
against AI instead so hey there's a way
to play free games without PS plus if
that floats your boat I write my own
jokes I imagine from PlayStation
grenades it's been a bloody pleasure
I'll see you next time